Okay.
Should be live here. Hello.
Just going to do um chill little stream
here. I'm pretty tired.
I went and maxed my bench.
And uh I'm burnt.
I had luckily I found this old
screenshot uh from Neural MMO.
So, I have a reference finally to
compare to. And yeah, we're definitely
way under
what we want here. What on earth is this
thing doing?
I have no idea what this thing is doing.
Did I run Wait, did I run this thing
without layer or am I an idiot? Um
No, we have that in here. It's fine.
Yeah, I just did it twice by mistake.
Close this.
Uh we can leave this here.
And I'll say what we're doing in a
second. So,
the main thing the main final
discrepancy that's preventing us from
releasing Neural MMO I mean not Neural
MMO, releasing Popper 4. And yeah, there
are experiments to run, yeah, there's
clean up and polish, and there's docs,
and there's writing.
But the main thing that we're missing,
hey Mystic, is the Neural MMO 3 results.
It's not working out good.
Um we don't know if it's an M-specific
bug, we don't know if it's a learning
bug.
So, what I'm going to do,
I'm going to go get the Python back-end
working because we know that one's
supposed to work.
And then we'll be able to run
essentially a confirmation check.
We'll be able to bisect the uh
the bug from there.
It's pretty important that I get this
process started
as quickly as possible because it's
going to take
50 bills. So, yeah, probably a minimum
of 4 hours
uh per experiment to verify.
Yeah, this was our uh this was the min
grid net as well. This was the previous
soda.
So, clear-cut soda, very nice.
From this comment.
I thought I'd remembered it only being
8.5. So, we did get nine
in the new update.
Okay, let's actually not run this
locally and kill the um
and kill my box. That's a better idea.
So, let's just do this on my remote one.
Unless they've got a um
an RTX
that's like not $10,000.
Um
Yeah, that's a bunch, too.
Great.
Got to reboot the container.
This is really the only goal for today
is to figure out this one bug.
I guess I'm pretty tired.
I'm traveling tomorrow.
And this is really the only thing that I
need before I enter the final like grind
for the finish line of um
of buffer four.
>> Okay, this works.
Good.
I got a 9k on the 5090, very good.
1 mil on the 5090, very good. Cool.
Uh
Why your screen recording looks so good
and mine looks so bad?
OBS, good connection,
good stream settings, like bit rate set
reasonably, 6 KB.
What are we going to do with our
vectorization?
Probably going to deprecate. No, we're
not going to deprecate the back. We're
just going to deprecate it for ocean
ends.
Be better.
>> I'll just kind of sit here and I'll like
fix things with this for a bit.
Um the goal will be if we can get
the old Python implementation working
nicely with the latest backends.
And then we can confirm that Neural MMO
still works with this.
Then we can track down discrepancies.
And if it doesn't work with this, then
we can also track down discrepancies,
but it'll take a little longer.
Okay, we did get rid of max mini batch
as well.
We cut it we cut a few like not really
used features
in buffer four.
Okay, there was a MP.
I guess we may as well keep that
Yes.
We did get rid of the num mini batches
config are.
We did introduce replay ratio though.
We'll see if it catches that.
Uh log format changes a lot. We don't
care too much about that initially.
Sure.
Not a big deal.
I don't really like the uh legacy.
Let me see.
Compile goes away.
Cool.
Oh, it actually doesn't even ask for the
clarification.
That's kind of funny. Sometimes you can
reject stuff and it'll just go, "Oh,
okay. Yeah, that was dumb." It doesn't
even ask for clarification.
How long is this file?
Yeah, this file is stupid long, but I
think most of it is um
the old sweep lock object.
We should be able to integrate all this
stuff nicely together.
I'm not going to do that yet, though.
Dashboard. So, this whole dashboard
print will get shared.
Um
Profile will probably still need here,
right?
But, this gets shared. This gets shared.
This gets deleted.
Train will use our main train loop. Eval
will use that loop.
All this code gets replaced.
I think it's going to be like
it's not going to be 400 lines. It'll
probably be like 800.
That's still way better.
We could technically expose our min
group to torch.
That might not be terrible.
Just wrap like the outermost min group
thing to torch.
We probably get some like reasonably
decent train rates with that, right?
Yeah.
I might still decide to do that just so
we give the torch users something,
right?
Cuz otherwise it'll be like, "Hey,
puffer four, it's five times faster with
our CUDA back end and it's slower
without it."
We don't really want
>> [clears throat]
Okay.
So, this is non-threaded version.
>> Do we want the CPU ones?
Why is it doing this?
Expose the raw CPU pinned buffer
pointers.
Not done C++ watch.
That's fine.
We'll clean this up after, so like we
won't have these multiple back ends. I
don't mind a little bit of bloat in the
bindings file though for this. I really
just want to have this test done for the
day.
GPU obs rewards terminals
Yeah, that's it.
FP4
for inference, right?
No way you train on FP4.
I don't even know how the hell you get
the model. I mean
I guess we need to see the charts. Like
can you actually quantize models to FP4
and not just destroy them?
Yeah.
I've definitely seen people complain
that they're being served like quantized
models that suck.
FP4 seems quite sus. Like I'd believe
that PA maybe.
Yeah, it's lossy. It's very lossy, of
course.
Hello, what is the plan for today?
The The plan for today is I'm exhausted,
so I'm chilling here and I'm attempting
to fix
uh
an issue with Neural MMO3 is not
training as well as it should. And that
is the main final test we need for
Puffer 4.
So, I'm getting our Python back end
cleaned up because I was going to end up
having to do that next week anyways.
But, I figure if we run Neural MMO in
the Python back end, that'll give us a
nice counterpoint test.
So, we're going to do that now.
Is there really a point to it?
If AMD actually makes a big push to
release sane stuff
um for ML, then sure, but like
they don't seem to give a [ __ ] about
their platform for that, so why should
I?
Like on one hand, it does somewhat
irritate me, right? But like
our very optimized back end is just
going to be for Nvidia hardware.
But like on the other hand we'll have a
reasonably efficient implementation with
torch. It could get swapped for tinygrad
in the future. Those will support
multiple back ends. And like ultimately
we need to be at the lowest level
for our main work going forward anyways.
Like I don't think it's possible for me
to effectively do the research that I
need to do in torch
or in tinygrad.
Like I need to be thinking at I need to
be thinking about architecture design
and the algorithms at the level of the
actual hardware, not at the level of
torch, which just like "Yeah, it's a
GPU. It does operations. You give us
operations, we'll do that."
>> Just
Whatever.
It can mess with the bindings file a
little bit for now.
I haven't bothered like I have to clean
that one up anyways.
As long as it doesn't mess with pop for
11.
Again, it can mess with this file.
The Python one is fine.
>> I will actually have to think a little
bit about um
uh nth parallelism.
It might be possible to give it a torch
fallback technically.
If I can do it in a way that's not
gross, I think it'll be worth it. We'll
see.
Um
Torch one doesn't have to be crazy crazy
optimized.
I think that we just don't introduce a
bunch of complexity into the torch code.
Like
the torch code is for people who don't
understand low-level and don't
understand optimized code.
You know?
I think it's better we have the like
really fast optimized thing, and then we
have the like, "Yeah, it's as fast as we
can get it while keeping it simple."
Did I not think of
Charles here?
Probably.
We might just have to expose it.
Infinite patience to set up the whole
chess project and dum-dum.
Stop after playing the AI and beat it.
Well, hey. I mean, we want we want
people using the stuff and contributing,
so
take a look around, see what stuff you
feel like building. There are a heck of
a lot of ways to get involved and
I hope advance the field for buffer.
Like you got to realize I only have so
much energy to go around.
So, there are a lot of ways to help out
with stuff.
>> Okay.
Um
Tell me something about chess bot. It
completely outplayed me to bits.
Had mate in nine completely winning, but
repeatedly failed. Yeah, we know that
there's it's weird with endgames for
whatever reason. It should be way easier
for it to learn, but it's bad at end
games.
Like the thing with end games, right? Is
end games are really easy for search cuz
there's not that much to search over.
Uh it's harder for RL.
Kind of funny, honestly, that it works
like that.
I mean, it's cool though that it like
It's cool that it plays differently from
a lot of other stuff, right?
That's kind of cool.
>> You try out. I haven't tried it yet. Did
he post it?
I definitely would like to.
Oh, [ __ ] Well, let's see.
Ooh.
This is based on my inferno thing, yeah?
>> You open the PRI, we'll have a lot of
fun with that.
>> He's a mech engineer. That's cool.
I just know how to chop wood in
Runescape.
Yeah, well, I know how to have this
thing on my other monitor like AFK in
this pure. That's what I'm not even
doing.
>> [laughter]
>> Of course I have it up in the
background. You You don't think that I
uh
did my PhD on it and I don't have it up
in the background, right? On the
freaking MMO AI.
No, Runescape is actually going to be In
my mind, it's like no question that this
is the right task.
Uh it's just on the side monitor.
Like woah, woah, you know?
Yeah, this is the uh
This is the silly little account I
sometimes have up running on the side.
I left this like 3K off of 99. I can
both at the same time.
And proper balance a game.
Uh yeah, for specific types of games you
can totally do that. That is a good
application for it in fact.
I stopped playing it for almost 3 years
I believe. Is it 2 years or 3? Think it
was almost 3 uh 3 years while I was
building Pupper 1 and 2. Pupper 1, 2,
and 3 in fact.
Uh recently I decided that okay, I
deserve a little bit of a break.
>> I mean some of the work blocks I've done
on popper have just been like
ridiculously massive head stick.
Uh started with a very very bad RLN
finish.
It's like entirely external knowledge.
No mechanics.
Yeah, it's going to have to get wrapped
differently.
>> It's going to want to wrap this
separately
from the right input, which is my thing.
That's what it'll do.
This is just a three binding syntax.
Small stream, probably small stream and
ish.
I'll be here another hour and a half ish
until dinner.
I might do the even like evening stream
though depending what we get done. I The
only thing I want to have today is I
want to have this thing this back end to
be able to test neural MMO 3.
So um cuz I'm doing some traveling
tomorrow so I'd like to get some
experiments in
while I am to confirm whether neural MMO
3 is screwed up or not.
>> I should I I can just have it make Well,
Yeah, I can just do this.
Well, we don't need the language model
to delete a line of code.
Yeah, it runs.
Cool.
See.
Did he?
Um
Yeah, there's too much mass here.
I'll be right back. Can I use the
restroom real quick while this goes on?